Now I'd like to introduce
you to our speakers today.
Our first speaker is Eric Shaqfeh, who
is the Lester Levi Carter Professor and
Department Chair of Chemical Engineering
at Stanford University.
He earned a BSE Summa **** Laude
from Princeton University.
And a MS and PhD from Stanford University,
all in Chemical Engineering.
He joined the Stanford Chemical
Engineering Faculty in early 1990.
And in 2001 he received
a dual appointment, and
became professor of
mechanical engineering.
He is most recently a faculty member
in the Institute of Computational and
Mathematical Engineering at Stanford.
He has authored or
co-authored over 180 publications, and
has been an associate editor of
The Physics of Fluids since 2006.
Shaqfeh has been awarded
the APS Francois and Frankiel award,
the NSF Presidential Young Investigator
award, the David and
Lucile Packard Fellowship in Science and
Engineering, among many others.
He is a fellow of
the American Physical Society, and
a member of the National Academy
of Engineering.
Lisa Hwang is a senior lecturer in
the chemical engineering department, and
is co-academic director of
the Stanford chemical engineering
online master's degree program.
She received her B.S. in chemical
engineering from MIT, and her MS and
PhD in chemical engineering from Stanford.
Working with the Kurt Frank group on
polymer thin foams and interfaces.
She has served as a lecture consultant for
the Office for the Vice for Teaching and
Learning, and
is the faculty director of TA training for
the chemical engineering department.
She has been teaching in
the department since 2006.
Elizabeth Sattely is an Assistant
Professor in the department of
Chemical Engineering at Stanford, and
a Stanford ChEM-H faculty fellow.
She also serves as an honorary
adjunct staff scientist,
at the Carnegie Institution of Science.
Doctor Sattely completed her graduate
training at Boston College in
Organic Chemistry, and
her post-doctoral studies in
Bio-Chemistry at Harvard Medical School,
where she worked on natural
product biosynthesis in bacteria.
Inspired by human reliance on plants and
plant derived molecules for medicine,
the Sattely laboratories focused on
the discovery and engineering of plant
metabolic pathways, to make molecules
that can enhance human and plant health.
Work in the Sattely lab has been
recognized by a NIH New Innovator Award,
a DOE Early Career Award,
An HHMI Simons Faculty Scholar Award,
and an AAAS Mason Award for
Women in the Chemical Sciences.
And finally, Alexander Dunn is an
Associate Professor in the Department of
Chemical Engineering at
Standford University.
His research focuses on understanding how
living cells sense mechanical stimuli,
with particular interests in stem
cell biology and tissue engineering.
Dr. Dunn worked as
a post-doctoral scholar with Jane
in the department of bio-chemistry at the
Stanford University school of medicine.
He received his PhD at
the California Institute of Technology
under the direction of Harry Grey,
where his work focused on understanding
the catalytic mechanisms selected
CH bond oxidation by P450 enzymes.
His work has been recognized with numerous
awards including the Hertz fellowship,
Jane Coffin Childs
postdoctoral fellowship,
the Burroughs Welcome Career Award
at the Scientific Interface, and
NIH director's New Innovator Award.
So, an amazing panel that we have today.
So, now I'd like to start by turning
the floor over to Eric and Lisa.
All right, today we're here to discuss
the introduction of a new online
Master's Degree in Chemical Engineering,
and I would like to give you some
history and perspective On how
that came about in our department.
We've had a residential masters for
many years now.
Even near the beginning of the department.
Our department is somewhere
around 50 plus years old.
But we all thought that we actually
missing an audience with our masters
program, particularly the people who are
professionals working at companies that
wanted to get advanced education, but
essentially were working full time jobs.
So we wanted to open the access to this,
and
we now have a faculty that's of that size
that we can actually do such a thing,
so this is the introduction
of a new program.
We're targeting a new audience,
we have our own new admissions program for
that degree.
And we'd like to talk to you about some of
the specifics so that we encourage you,
if you have this interest, to apply
to our online master's degree program
now through March 19th for this go around.
Ultimately, our program was structured
with these two goals in mind,
to provide greater access, as I mentioned,
to a population perhaps we
weren't reaching for before.
And also, Stanford is an amazing place
where you can structure a degree,
and we're giving you the flexibility
to structure that degree, in a way that
combines a very internationally top-ranked
chemical engineering institution,
with a wide range of engineering
coursework that's offered at Stanford.
So you can structure a program
within your interest set.
With an interest set that perhaps has
interests outside chemical engineering,
such as entrepreneurship, artificial
intelligence, biological studies,
etc., and still obtain a very
first-rank online master's program.
We structured it to accomplish
these goals in the following way.
We're going to ask you to
complete 45 academic units,
all offered by the online learning.
27 units in chemical engineering,
8 graduate level courses and
one engineering seminar.
And those courses will have
in them not just you folks,
the online masters folks, but also Our PhD
students, our residential masters, etc.
And these will be taught by our regular
faculty, all of them, on a regular basis.
Beyond that then, we add the flexibility
that you can, as I said,
structure the program so you can look
at other interests that you might have,
that will be supplementary,
to you interest in chemical engineering.
And that means that you can take 18
units in engineering, science, or
math electives,
200-level classes or above, for
any of the online offerings that
are presently offered within Stanford.
Lisa, who's the director
of the program and
myself are going to review
your program sheets.
And particularly we're going to look
at programs which have three or
four electives in a single topical area.
Again, that's part of our programming
when people who have to combine
the chemical engineering,
with an area that they are interested in.
And then two or
three other electives that might be
things that they've never taken before,
that they have just an interest in.
Again, it's a 45 unit program,
27 units in chemical engineering and
18 units In engineering,
science, or math electives.
I'm now going to hand it over to Lisa, and
she's going to tell you a little bit
more detail about the program that we've
structured.
>> All right, thanks Eric.
So the way our program is structured,
is that we ask you to take four
core chemical engineering courses.
These are 300-level courses
that you can see below.
We are offering five of
our core courses online,
as you can see here you will choose four.
And then we'd also have you
choose four additional electives
within the chemical engineering
graduate programs that we offer online.
And these range from anything from
to entrepreneurship and
the engineering and sciences.
So even within the chemical
engineering requirements,
you do have some breadth
in terms of the electives.
And we have,
as you can see from our core courses,
we really have the size of
the molecular engineering perspective.
And you will see this throughout all
of your course work in the department.
Now regarding your elective, topical
areas, or areas of focus, we're really
fortunate that Stanford has a wealth
of online graduate engineering courses.
That are offered online every quarter and
we encourage you to
take advantage of this.
Think about what would
be most beneficial for
you and your goals for
obtaining this degree.
You might have a concentration in
entrepreneurship, applied math,
modeling, optimization, etc.
This is really where you get to tailor
the program to meet your needs.
Sorry, go ahead, Eric.
>> Let me say just a little
bit about that, as Lisa's going to show
you now on the website for the program.
We have taken the time to actually
write down subgroups of courses
which fit underneath these areas
which you might be interested in.
And so therefore we encourage
you to go to the website,
to go to VPTL's description
of these courses.
So that you get an idea as to what
your program would look like and
how it fits your interests.
>> Great, so
what we're showing you here is just
two of these preselected courses.
That we thought would be
of interest to folks, for
example who are interested
in entrepreneurship.
You can see that in
addition to the world-class
chemical engineering course work.
We are surrounded by great colleagues
who are discussing entrepreneurship from
potentially a management science and
engineering perspective.
Or you might be interested in
learning about this from a civil and
environmental engineering stance.
Optimization and control, again,
you have great opportunities
to take advantage of
expertise in the department.
From double Management Science and
Engineering.
You get to craft and tailor your
concentration from the perspective
that you are particularly interested in.
>> We're going to seed,
in some sense the questions with a couple
that we imagine would be some of
the most appropriate or
interesting to you.
So let's start this question about,
what is the time of completion?
Again, this is in some sense self-paced,
we imagine people taking one or
two courses a quarter and
then finishing the 45 units.
If you do take one course a quarter,
you can do the math,
you can complete this in about three and
a half years.
But we imagine some people will take
as much as five years to do it,
some people might have the time to
do it in a shorter period of time.
But again, it's self-paced, and that's
part of the advantage of this program,
that you can do it,
in some sense, in your own time.
The second question, I am interested
in a PhD in chemical engineering,
is this program right for me?
If you want to get a PhD
in chemical engineering,
you probably don't want
to take this program.
We have very few of our residential
master students making the transition
to the PhD program because frankly,
the requirements are very, very different.
You structured this program as a terminal
online master's experience for
professionals who want education
in chemical engineering and
then in other related fields.
So the short answer is, no,
of course, we will consider an application
for PhD and chemical engineering,
but it's really not a prep for
the PhD it's a terminal program.
And then the third question is, I may
prefer to attend classes on campus, so
suppose you want to
switch either direction?
We've structured the program such that
they are very, very complementary.
So this would be relatively simple,
that is to say,
if you're taking the online masters.
You are satisfying residential
masters requirements and
therefore you could make the switch.
However, we would like to control
the number of people that switch so
we will consider petitions for this
switch and restrict the number per year.
Lisa did you have anything more?
>> No, I think that covers it,
Eric, thanks.
>> Thanks guys.
So now I'd like to present Alex Dunn,
who's going to be our next speaker.
I know Alex has
a commitment after this so,
I do want to encourage people that have
questions during his presentation.
To submit them in the Q and A box, and
you can ask him before he has to leave.
Fun fact about Alex, he recently
submitted a paper to the journal,
Science about a special protein that
gives a cell physical structure.
That work can ultimately help us
think about regenerative medicine.
And how we can engineer human
stem cells to form tissues and
organs to replace what's been
lost to accident, disease.
He's exploring some really interesting
questions in his research,
so it's my pleasure to hand off to Alex.
So he can talk about his work in his
upcoming spring quarter course that you
can take with him.
>> Great, well, thank you very much,
and thank you all for coming to visit,
if virtually with us today.
So I'll begin by just
mentioning in a few minutes my
research lab's interests, and
that is really very simple.
You and I and the mouse you see on
your screen all began as a relatively
undifferentiated mass of cells, and yet
we complex and beautiful organisms.
And as an engineer this provokes
a very simple question.
How did that happen, and how can
we recapitulate that process in the lab in
order to build new replacement tissues?
So the goals of my lab
are to understand how biology
builds itself from molecules up.
And importantly, to understand
the physical rules by which cells work
together to construct living tissues.
So for example,
in the story we published a few years ago,
we performed simple experiments
on zebrafish embryos,
these are little fish,
just like you'd see in a pet store.
We learned some simple rules about how
the tissues arrange themselves and
we're now applying those rules.
To try to understand how groups of stem
cells work together in the lab in order to
build a complex tissue that could be
used for regenerative medicine purposes.
Now as part of that study,
we're really interested in the sensors and
actuators inside every cell in your body.
You can think of these as
nanometer-sized string gauges or
even muscles but
scaled down to the nanometer length scale.
Importantly, these molecular assemblies
actually perform both mechanical
functions and also compute information.
Something I would love to talk
about with you at greater length.
Now in one such study,
we used advanced light
imaging to try to understand how living
cells move through solid tissues and
how they remodel their
physical surroundings.
And what we found is that these cells
are powered by contractile struts
as you see in this movie.
Where we used advanced image processing to
track the movement of individual protein
complexes within a living cell.
And one way to think about
it is that these cells,
which happen to be the cells that repair
wounds, for instance in your skin.
Actually, it's the same design principles
in order to generate force and
motion is this sort of
creepy looking cheetah robot
that was created a few years
ago by Boston Dynamics.
We are of course here to talk
about the classes that I teach,
there are two classes, if time allows,
I'll discuss both of them.
The first which I'm teaching next
quarter is called Chemical Kinetics and
Reaction Engineering.
And it tells stories in that class that
leads to the images you see on the screen.
Now, here is the syllabus, and
our approach to this topic is a little
bit different in this department
than in this other departments.
It focuses very much on the fundamentals
that drive chemical reactivity.
So we start with transition state theory,
the question of how reactions occur.
And as I'll show you in the next slide,
we also think about the deep connections
between the kinetics of chemical
reactions and basic statistical physics.
We then move on to understanding the basic
rules that underlie as modern and
predictive understanding
of heterogeneous catalysis.
And explore their deep connections
with the same rules that control
how biological enzymes work.
We then finish with an introduction
to systems biology and
systems of coupled reactions and
transport.
Now, this is a practical example.
Here is the Monsanto process,
which is used in an industrial scale
to produce acetic acid, usually within,
if my memory serves, an iridium
rather than rhodium based catalyst.
Now, in this laboratory study, it was
discovered that despite the presence
of eight species and
corresponding number of reactions.
The overall rate was dictated by
the concentration when we choose species.
Using very simple principles, this also
called to determine why that is and
use that information to
optimize reactivity.
As I mentioned earlier,
there really only a few physical
rules that govern chemical kinetics.
One of them is very simple
statistics of improbable events.
So in the first lecture of the course,
I'll explain to you why
the injuries to soldiers due to
poorly behaved horses in the Prussian
army actually led to the fundamental
mathematical understanding,
the drives are understanding
of chemical reactions.
So for example, unlike in most courses
on this topic, we'll actually perform
stochastic reactions to give you
insight on the chemical reactivity.
And allow you to model system with
small number of components as
would be common for
instance in some diagnostic applications.
The second topic in this course
is why do reactions happen and
what makes them faster slope.
So here is just an example slide showing
one fundamental result in the field,
transition state theory that
relates the rate of a reaction to
a ratio of patrician coefficients
Q double dagger and QA.
This provides deep and beautiful
connections between our understanding of
statistical mechanics and
of chemical reactivity.
As the quest progresses we
move on to more modern topics.
I'm particularly enthusiastic
about de novo design and
functional enzymes for both laboratory and
industrial application.
And this is a topic that I think will have
enormous importance in the coming years.
Now, that's the most relevant and
immediate information.
I should mention that I also teach a
second online course on Biochemistry, it's
quite complimentary to the advanced topics
taught by my colleague, Professor Sattely.
And just like in Kinetics I teach
that course around stories involving
all of the things you,
You see you on your screen there.
Now, why study metabolism?
Which is really the basic concept in
this course, is human metabolism.
Well, human disease is one very
important and obvious application.
Perhaps slightly less obvious,
but still pretty immediate,
is the connection to synthetic biology.
The rules you'll learn in this
class will allow you to construct,
in a rational way, complex molecules,
like the antimalarial Artemisinin.
And then finally this course
provides foundational knowledge for
understanding how the beautiful,
natural world around us works.
Now, the underlying insight in this course
is how to go from complex information
like this metabolic network I'm
showing here to fundamental insight.
In other words, how to pack detail into
your head in a way that makes sense and
it allows you to make practical
decisions in the future.
All right, that's all of my material.
I can answer a few questions
if you're interested.
>> We did have a question come in for you,
Alex.
>> Great.
>> So someone asked, within your course do
you explore how small chemical changes
impact IPSCs to form teratomas,
or how other cell culture errors develop?
>> Yes, indeed, we do.
So for those of you who may not
know those acronyms, that's
Induced Pluripotent Stem Cells, which is a
powerful substrate for tissue engineering.
We're especially interested in how
the interplay between mechanical cues
like tissue geometry or mechanical
forces within the tissue combine with
the biochemical signals that the cell
receives in order to tell the cell live,
die, divide, differentiate or
stay the same.
These are the rules that construct us and
that I think it would be incredibly
important to understand for
tissue engineering.
All right.
>> Great,
I don't see any other questions
coming through quite yet.
So if anyone has any other questions for
Alex feel free to put them through.
But if we don't get a chance to follow up
because I know he needs to go to his other
commitment we'll certainly
do some follow-ups.
So thank you so much Alex for
taking the time today to speak.
>> My pleasure and happy to answer any
questions you may have.
>> Great.
>> Thank you.
>> All right,
so now I'm going to move
on to our next speaker.
I'd like to hand it over to Beth.
A fun fact about Beth,
she was recently named as one of the 47
investigators on
the Chan Zuckerburg bio hub.
Where she will be focusing
merging engineering and
detailed knowledge of plant biochemical
pathways to enhance health.
This bio hub initiative will invest
more than $50 million to support people
like Beth in her life science research.
So it's an exciting opportunity to take
her course and to learn from her so
now I'll hand it over to her.
Thanks Beth.
>> Great, thanks very much, Stephanie for
the introduction.
I want to start, by actually introducing
my lab, and my broader research program.
We're a collection of engineers and
scientists,
who are interested in plants as plants.
And what I mean by that, is the ability
of green plants to produce molecules,
at scale, that are critical for
life as we know it.
And so we're fascinated by the amazing
capacity of plants to take
the world's simplest building block,
carbon dioxide, and produce so
many molecules that are important to us,
for example, the food we eat.
These processes lead to the air we
breathe, biofuels we're considering for
renewable energy, as well as numerous
molecules that are either used in
the clinic or part of our diet
that influence our health.
And so
plants are already incredibly productive.
But we realized that modern tools and
genetic engineering,
which allow us to make multiple
simultaneous changes in
a complex organism's genome opens
the door for new possibilities.
So, I want to just introduce three grand
challenges that motivate the research in
my lab.
And as I'll tell you, also have
motivated some of the concepts I go
over in the course I teach
biochemical engineering.
So these challenges have to do with
altering the metabolism of plants.
Using these engineering tools, so for
example if we have molecules from plants
that we've used in the clinic,
it's critical to know
that many of these compounds are produced
by plants that are difficult to cultivate,
or by plant cell culture, which can be
an inefficient source of these molecules.
And so we'd like to use engineered
metabolism, or engineered biosynthesis,
to come up with a new way to
manufacture these particular compounds.
We're also interested in how the chemistry
of plants influences plant fitness,
and furthermore how it can be
engineered to enhance plant fitness.
The small molecules plants produce,
are critical for
allowing plants to obtain the nutrients
they need to grow and prevent disease,
and grow in less desirable areas, for
example, high salinity or drought.
And finally, another area in my lab that
has to do with chemistry of plants and
human health, has to do with
optimizing nutrition in our diet, so
really using a metabolic engineering
approach, to make plants healthier.
And so again, these grand challenges
motivate the work in my group, and
also how I approach ChemEng
355 Biochemical Engineering.
So in this course is I'll tell you,
my goal is to really present the tools and
concepts that are required, to really
build any engineered biological system.
So as i have shown in the circle
that could be an engineered cell,
it could be an engineered higher
organism such as a plant.
But we're going to modify machinery,
from DNA, to RNA, to protein to either
product or function,
to obtain new chemical functionality.
And so some of these things you can think
about are maybe ones you've heard before,
for example the production of antibiotics
in cells, or the production of therapeutic
proteins, but there are a lot
of new possibilities as well.
How could we engineer cells
to produce fuels or plastics?
Or even small molecules that
you don't even find in nature.
On the function side, again we can think
about using cells as essentially tools and
machines for information storage,
cell based therapies, and
even on the whole organism scale again.
For example, non-browning apples is a
recent example from the agriculture side.
And so within these challenges comes
the framework for the course objectives.
And so my goal is not to have a collection
of students with an expansive knowledge
of biology, but to deliver in this course
the basic concepts and the language
of biochemical engineering, that would
allow you to build any engineered system.
And so at the end of the course,
once you finish,
my objective is that Any new process that
you hear about, either in the news or
a colleague has worked on, or something
that's being developed at a company.
You understand each of the components
required to build that system from
scratch, using quantitative principles.
I'd also like to convey, especially
towards the second half of the course,
ideas about, what are the limits
of biochemical engineering?
What new tools might we need to develop?
And what's on the horizon?
What are some of the frontiers and
challenges in this field?
And so, the course is really
organized into two parts.
In the beginning, we go through some of
the background biology that builds on
much of the things that Alex,
my colleague, talked about.
In terms of fundamentals of biological
systems, what aspects of a cell do you
need to understand, in order to be able
to engineer the chemistry of a cell?
We do this using a quantitative approach.
For example, rates in biological systems,
and rates of central dogma, so
that we can really think about
how to apply process and
engineering controls to get
the output that we're interested in.
In the second half of the course,
once we have this understanding
starting from a piece of DNA,
going to a cell and an organism level,
what are some of the applications?
So how might we generate
proteins with new function, or
metabolic pathways with
a different output?
And then, how do we think about scaling
up and process considerations for
these applications?
And so, I want to just close
with one example from my lab,
which is a complex process, and really,
a challenge that the principles that
you learned in chemical engineering
355 could help you adjust.
So, one of the things that we were really
interested in Is an anti-cancer agent,
Atopicide, that's used in many
clinically applied chemotherapeutics.
So this is a molecule that's currently
produced from a plant, a medicinal plant,
that's very difficult to cultivate and
in fact,
there is often [INAUDIBLE] sources
of this particular molecule.
So in recent years shortages
have been reported by the FDA,
in part because we have no good
way of manufacturing this drug,
beyond isolation from the medicinal plant.
And so the challenge for
us is could we rebuild biology?
Could we take that metabolic pathway
from this medicinal plant, and
engineer it as a way to
produce this compound.
And so what we needed to do was
identify genes, we needed a source for
each of these pieces of DNA.
We needed to control how they
might be expressed in a chassis.
And we needed to find ways to
keep those genes in our chassis,
and get to the output of interest.
And so we've been able to do this
in my lab, take the genes for
a medicinal plant, and transfer them to
a much easier to cultivate and grow plant,
Nicotiana which is a wild
relative of tobacco.
So thinking back to
Biochemical Engineering 355,
in that course we'll learn about
all the steps of a process.
Whether you want to take the genes
from a medicinal plant and
put them into a chassis like tobacco, or
you want to build an engineered T cell or
some other process in engineering.
Great, thanks so much Beth.
So as a reminder, if you have questions
for Beth, please submit them into the Q&A
box, it's an amazing opportunity
to ask her questions.
If we don't see any at the moment,
which I don't see any specific to Beth,
we'll have some time at the end for
the Q&A for her to answer.
So please don't be shy about
submitting those questions.
So next I want to talk a little bit
about online learning at Stanford.
So the online learning experience is
the next best thing to being here
on campus at Stanford.
Faculty are giving lectures that we
capture and post for our online students,
that are held in special classrooms.
So at the same time that we're
lecturing on campus students,
we're also capturing their lectures.
There are features within the video player
like bookmarking, creating important clips
that you want to review later, and
notes that you can add to lecture videos.
And there are several ways to interact
with the teaching teams such as
office hours, forums, and project work.
So here's a great example of what
the video player looks like.
You can see Alex Dunn is featured right
there in his Biochemistry 2 class.
As you can see on the bottom right,
you can add bookmarks and
clips by clicking on those icons and
create notes.
If you need to review a concept that
Alex has explained you can simply
watch it again, which is really nice.
And these lecture videos are archived and
available to the students
throughout the quarter.
So, a great resource for
those online learners.
I want to talk a little bit
about our enrollment, so
the Spring quarter enrollment period
is open now through March 19th for
the master's degree program.
So over a month still to take
advantage of this deadline.
Follow these steps starting
with the grad admissions link,
keep in mind the GRE is required,
three letters of recommendation,
a statement of purpose,
and academic transcripts.
If you aren't quite ready to apply
to the Master's Degree program, but
you want to get your feet wet by taking
some graduate level courses for credit,
you can start as a non-degree option
student with the Stanford Center for
Professional Development.
The GRE and
letters of rec are not required,
as you can seem the transcripts,
are required.
You start what we like to call NDO,
an NDO application with us.
And you can take courses for credit and
apply up to 18 units towards the Masters
degree program, should you get accepted.
So that's really nice.
So as we head into end
of our presentation,
again we're going to transition into
the Q and A portion of the webinar.
Please be sure to submit your
questions into the Q and A box, so
we can take advantage of the time we have
with these wonderful presenters today.
As you submit those questions,
I want to remind you here that
the Chemical Engineering Department
is currently taking applications for
this exciting new online degree program.
You can learn more by going to
their chemical engineering website,
and the application
deadline is March 19th.
As mentioned before, if you want to just
get your feedback by being a non degree
option student to start, we have two
wonderful chemical engineering graduates
certificates that you can start with.
As mentioned before, after 18 units it
can be applied to master degree program.
This is our biotechnology graduate
certificate that actually includes
CHEM ENG 355 with [INAUDIBLE].
So just so you're aware of that.
We also have, as our next certificate,
the Energy Engineering and
Technologies Graduate Certificate.
That you can explore as well as
you're ramping up to apply for
the master's degree program.
Information on both of
these certificates and
the courses that are involved can
be found at scpd.standford.edu.
Again, I want to make mention of
two amazing courses that Beth and
Alex are teaching this
upcoming spring quarter.
Of course, that CHEMENG355
that Beth was talking about,
Advanced Biochemical Engineering and
the CHEMENG320,
Chemical Kinetics and
Reaction Engineering.
So those are going to be available for
those who apply and
are accepted into the master's
degree program and
also if you choose to take it
as a non-degree option student.
And spring enrolment is also
open until March 19th for
the non-degree option students.
Okay, so
we're going to head into the Q & A.
We already have some
questions that have come up.
So-
>> Can I say something or no?
>> Yeah, go ahead, Eric, yes.
>> Let me just say, so you saw how
the exciting,
wonderful content of these courses.
And we focus this webinar
on two vignettes associated
with courses that are actually
available in the spring.
But in fact, similar stories exist for
all of our courses.
In energy, in catalysis,
in solar cell science, etc.
So it covers the broad range, and
what we've tried to do is open this up to
people that may not have the opportunity
to be in residence at Stanford.
But still have the opportunity to have
this real exciting learning experience.
That was the faculty's vision and
goal and I hope you take the chance to
take this opportunity.
>> Thank you so much, Eric.
>> Yeah.
>> All right,
so the first question that
is posed to the group.
Are students in the online master's
program eligible to participate in
the research labs of professors?
>> The original
concept was that there would
be a research component to it.
Right now, we don't require it.
I believe you could apply to do
a research component of that.
It's not required in
the program right now, and
we would consider that But
right now it isn't part of the program.
It might be in the future.
Of course, that requires residence
usually to do lab work, and so
we were trying to divide those two.
Our master's students, the residential
master's students typically do some aspect
of research as part of their program.
>> Great, the next question we have is,
how will lab activities or hands on
activities be handled with this online
program?
>> Yeah, as I think I mentioned there,
are no lab courses that are included
right now in the curriculum.
If there are lab modules that
are part of the teaching,
then they would be handled online.
So you would see the lab module externally
but you wouldn't participate in
hands on experience.
>> The next question is maybe not specific
to the lab but just in general,
are there research opportunities for
students in the online program?
>> Yeah,
again, we have not required
it in the program but
we would accept you could ask to
participate in research opportunities.
And we would be willing to consider
that and the faculty would be, but
we don't have any requirements for that.
So in some sense, that would be in
addition to the present requirements.
Did you have anything to say [INAUDIBLE]?
>> No, I mean, I think our faculty would
be open to interested students,
just as they are welcome.
Our residential master students have
access to the faculty to explore
some options as well.
So if this is a particularly
strong interest,
I'm sure the student can engage with
the faculty that they're interested in.
>> Yeah, let's just be clear,
we have students at all levels
undergraduate, master's and
visiting scholars participating
in research activities.
Actually all the graduates from
all across the country and
the world participating in research
opportunities within our faculties' labs.
And so that is definitely available
to you on the online program.
We didn't require it because
it requires residency.
>> Okay, the next question is, and
we may have answered this already.
Are online courses live or pre-recorded?
I don't know if you guys have any
pre-recorded flipped situations.
But I think most of them are-
>> Most of them are live and
then recorded, if that's the thing.
As I think about it, there might be
some if the faculty's out of town,
where he'll use some prerecorded
classes in those spots.
But generally right now they're live and
recorded.
Do you have any?
>> No, so if you're an online student,
you will be watching the video content
asynchronous from the actual class,
the on campus version of the class.
>> Yes, but
they are live and recorded.
>> Someone has asked, I'm interested in
polymers, I work in the plastics industry.
>> Yes.
>> What kind of courses are related
to polymers and are they available?
>> Yes, we have,
well, let's see, online right now.
>> I don't believe
we are in this academic year
offering our polymers course online.
But it is certainly something we
could consider for the future.
We also have a variety of materials
science courses that go into polymers,
polymer physics and polymer applications
that might be of interest that
are offered online.
>> We have 162 and 262,
which will come back next year.
It's taught this year but not online.
>> Okay.
>> But it will come back next year, and
we can have it taught online
if there is interest.
That would be a good thing to do.
>> Great.
>> It's been taught online
in the past.
>> Yes.
>> So another question that has come in.
Someone asked,
I have a degree in industrial engineering.
I am currently working in adhesives
industry and my career path requires for
me to strengthen my chemistry knowledge.
Is this masters degree right for me?
>> It's pretty darn good for
you, let's put it that way.
There's a lot of chemistry and
chemistry-related processing
that is in this curriculum.
Much more so than on the physics side, so
I would have to say yes.
>> Great.
>> Someone asked do I need to enroll in
one of the graduate certificate programs
biotechnology or energy engineering.
Or can I take one or more individual
courses related to my area of interest.
And I can answer that
question by saying certainly
people can take standalone courses.
They don't need to enroll in
a certificate program in order to take
classes.
>> Right.
>> They just need to
meet those prerequisites.
But I don't know if you want to talk to,
I know you're involved in developing those
graduate certificates with the benefits
of taking those [CROSSTALK].
Right, so
we developed the certificates before
we're developing this online masters.
And the express idea now is that if you're
taking those graduate certificates, you
can transfer as many of those units over
if you now want to get the online masters.
So we hope that's a very smooth path for
you, and as Stephanie said,
up to 18 units, so
that works very, very well.
18 units is actually, I believe,
slightly more than any of the,
to complete the certificates, so
therefore you're in good shape.
If you're in a certificate, or want to
take a certificate courses, and then,
ultimately, you want to
take the online Master's,
that transition should be seamless.
>> Someone has asked, I'm a mechanical
engineer, is this Master's degree
program potentially right for me?
>> Yeah, so we don't, so let's put it this
way, we don't differentiate
in the application process.
So we have applications from chemistry
students, mechanical engineers,
physicists, etc.
Now, with that said,
many of these courses have pre-reqs.
If you haven't, if you can't, or can't
say that you've satisfied the pre-req, or
prove to the faculty member who's teaching
the course that you satisfied the pre-req,
then of course you'd have to take
the lower level courses that are required
as pre-reqs for these courses, and some of
them are online and some of them are not.
So it's specific from that point of view,
but from our point of view we
don't differentiate, so mechanical
engineers will be part of our program.
>> Great.
So, someone has said, hello,
I'm very interested in this
Master's degree program.
So that's great, we already have some
positive feedback, I have some questions,
but the main one I think is this,
do I have to be in the United States or
have studied my Bachelor's
in the States to apply?
>> Well, that's certainly not true,
because we admit PhD's and Master's all
the time from foreign institutions.
So, the short answer is absolutely
we welcome your application and
it'll be considered just like all of our
graduate applications from overseas.
There's a TOEFL requirement?
That's in addition to, no?
>> Is that the case,
okay.
>> Yeah,
there's a TOEFL requirement that's in
addition to the requirements that you saw,
but apart from that, it'll be considered
with all the other applications.
>> Okay,
I think we're pretty set with questions.
Do you guys want to add
anything else before I close?
>> I would just say,
feel free to reach out to us
if you have any questions or
would like to just discuss thematic
areas that might be of interest or
anything about the program.
We're happy to answer any
questions that you guys may
have.
>> Yeah,
I hope our email addresses are available
on the website so that they can
send questions online if they need to.
>> Sure.
>> We'll get them answered.
It may not be instantaneous, but
we'll get them answered.
>> Right, and
we fully expect that questions will
come in for the Master's degree program,
in both the Chemical Engineering
Department and the Stanford Center for
Professional Development are committed to
answering your questions, and making sure
to put you on the right path should
this be something you want to pursue.
>> That's right, and again,
we're gearing up for
this being our first class by March 19th,
so please take a look at all the materials
that are available on the website.
>> Right, okay great.
So, I want to just close by saying thank
you to Eric, Lisa, Beth, and Alex.
Alex had to leave, but all for a wonderful
presentation about this new online degree
program, and for answering all the
questions that came through on the Q&A.
A reminder,
application deadline is March 19th.
Check out the chemical engineering
website for more information, and
definitely check out, we have all of the
course pages on our SCPD website as well,
so please check those out.
We will be sending out the recording
within a week to all those who
registered for the webinar, and just thank
you for taking the time to attend today.
We really hope to see you in
the future in this new exciting
Chemical Engineering
Online Degree Program.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you very much.